قوات الاحتلال الاسرائيلي انسحبت بشكل
جزئي من مدينه جنين ليس بالكامل هناك بعض
النقاط لازالت قوات الاحتلال تنتشر فيها
اضافه بالطبع الى نشر قناصه ووحدات خاصه
وبالتالي لازال هناك حاله من الهدوء ولكنه
الحذر الشديد
اي بعد عمليه عسكريه واسعه شملت كل انحاء
الضفه الغربيه والمدن الرئيسيه هذا جزء من
دمار الذي الحقه الاحتلال الاسرائيلي في
احد شركات الصرافه يعني مثلا هذا بنك ليسه
علاقه بشركه الصرافه ولكن اعتقد الاحتلال
ان الخزنه التي تملكها شركه الصرافه التي
لها 11 فرعا في كل انحاء الضفه الغربيه
لديها هنا خزنه فتم تحطيم هذه النوافذ
اطلاق النار على كل من كان يتحرك وفق
صاحب الشركه الذي لازال رهن الاعتقال
اي ابناؤه يؤكدون والذين يعملون في هذه
الشركه يؤكدون ان قوات الاحتلال
الاسرائيلي اقتحمت منازلهم اقتادته بالقوه
تم تعنيفهم وتم ادخالهم الى هذه
ال الى بعض من فروع شركتهم التي كما ذكرنا
هي منتشره في كل انحاء الضفه الغربيه هذه
الشركه هي واحده من خمس شركات صرافه لديها
فروع في كل انحاء الضفه الغربيه يقول وزير
الدفاع الاسرائيلي ويتهم بعد ان اصدر يواف
جالانت قرارا يقضي بتصنيف خمس شركات صرافه
بفروعها في الضفه الغربيه على انها منظمات
ارهابيه وحسب زعمه بان ذلك ياتي في اطار
الحرب الاقتصاديه التي تشنها اي اسرائيل
على اي ال الاوال التي تحول الى حركه حماس
تحديدا وتنفيذا لهذا القرار تم مصادره
مبالغ في الضفه الغربيه تصل الى 3 ملايين
دولارات 3 ملايين دولار اضافه الى اعتقال
حوالي 20 فلسطينيا بينهم اصحاب وموظفون
يعملون في هذه الشركات بزعم كما ذكرنا
انها تعمل على تمويل الارهاب كما نرى معك
مياده هذه هي الخزنه الرئيسيه في داخلها
كان يوجد مبالغ نقديه تقدر تقريبا ب
300000 دولار امريكي كما نرى اصبحت فارغه
بالكامل اضافه الى سندات
ورقيه
وشكات و مستندات وخاصه ان هذه الشركه لها
ايضا فروع في الاستثمار
والاراضي ووفق الجيش الاسرائيلي في بيانه
فان وحده البرانيه في ما تعرف لهب 43
ثلاثه جرت اجرت تحقيقا مشتركا مع الجيش
وهيئه حظر تبييض الاموال وتمويل الارهاب
وجهاز الامن العام اي الشباك ووزاره
الداخليه وسلطه الضرائب ضد وصفتهم بالضفه
الغربيه للاشتباه بتورطهم في تمويل حركه
حماس بالم الاوال الرقميه والنقديه ضد
تحويل الاموال بينما يؤكد اصحاب هذه
المحلات بانهم لا يقومون الا بالعمل وفق
مستندات قانونيه